Just before we get started.
I do want to say that there's going to be a lot of French pronunciations in this
one.
Indeed.
The character of this video is Joan of arc.
I'm going with the accepted English pronunciation of her name.
If you want to have a go at me in the comments you can.
She's one of history's youngest warriors as an age when most of us were
stressing out about what to wear to school,
Joan of arc was leading thousands of French troops into battle against the
English,
supposedly inspired by divine visions of Catholicism's Greatest Saints Joan
first a copper sword at age 16 she was leading armies by 17 and she was burned
at the stake before she was even 20 in a short life.
She managed to change the course of the hundred years war ending English
domination of France.
Certainly not bad fun,
illiterate girl from the sticks,
but while most of us know the name Joan of Arc and no her tragic ends,
how much do we actually know about her life?
Well,
join us today as we take a look at this simple peasant girl who changed European
history before dying alone and disgraced,
convinced that she was a failure.
We don't know today the exact date of Jones birth.
All we know is that it was sometime in 1412 to a farming family of some means.
Now,
some means it is definitely a relative term.
Joan's village of Dom Remey in northeastern France was shockingly port still.
Her father is John managed to scrape together 50 acres of farmlands and the
family lived in the biggest house in the town for Young Joan life in don't run
the men's,
a life of sewing and taking care of animals as a girl in medieval Europe.
No one taught her to read and write or do other manly things.
They did teach her how to pray though.
Joan's mother Isabel Rami was a devout Catholic and how developed was sheep?
Well,
does evidence Isabelle may have made a pilgrimage to Rome earlier in life?
Crazy feat for a woman living at a time when traveling three villages over
mentor days riding and the knowledge that you might be killed by bandits,
but as well,
they've done a time when public devotion afforded a woman a certain level of
respect that was not found elsewhere.
Early 15th Century France was filled with female visionaries who it was taken as
fact could communicate with God.
While Isabelle herself never claimed to be a mystic,
she likely told young June all about these women still drones.
Early life was relatively uneventful.
She became a master seamstress.
She works on her dad's farm.
She made a handful of friends.
Had she been born at a different time.
It's downfall.
We'd be talking about her at all.
Heck,
it's doubtful those in dom Remey would have even remembered her,
but Joan wasn't born at any time.
She was born in 1412 in northern France and northern France in 1412 was a place
in the grip of a destructive conflicts.
Joan of arc had been born at slap bang in the middle of the hundred years war.
The Hundred Years War could win awards for the least accurately named historical
events.
In fact,
it was a series of wars between England and France and it lasted 116 years is
not a hundred now.
Normally what we do is we had mentioned the hundred years war and we're just
move on.
But Joan of arcs life was so short and so tied up in the hundred years war that
we'd have to keep holding the narrative every two seconds just to stop you from
going.
What's going on?
Seven.
So like a fun Pixar short here is our quick biography of the 100 years war.
That was not a hundred years and wasn't really a single war.
So 10 66 for Norman King William the conqueror earns his nickname by conquering
England's.
Crucially,
he retained his claim on the French thrown as did his descendants then eat 300
years later in 1328 King Charles the fourth of France,
he dies.
This was super good news for Williams descendant,
Edward the third who was next in line for the throne.
So at this point you've already thinking,
well,
I got news that we get two countries,
right?
Well,
no.
Instead,
the French crowns,
local Noble Phillip,
the Sig,
all while blowing raspberries across the channel at England's fed up with all of
these Frenchies taunting in his general direction.
Edward went to war with France in 1337 by 1360 everyone was tired of warring and
Edward accepted a trunk of northern France in return for abandoning his claims
to the throne.
So the warring,
it stops in cell 1380 when the French crowns crazy.
Charles the sick,
the guy who genuinely believed that he was made of gloss Charles the sixth was
sewing capable of ruling that he created a power vacuum in 1407 the French
houses of only on and Burgundy actually went to war to fill it.
The house of Bergen's.
He,
by the way,
that's an name you're going to want to remember.
So a year off to Joan was born in 1413 Henry the fifth was crowned King of
England,
desperate to revive his claims of the French throne.
Henry demanded to marry one of Charles the sixth,
his daughters the French.
In response to that,
we're pretty much like my arm that's not happening.
And England and France,
they went to war yet again.
But this time the house of Burgundy allied with the English,
this led to the Treaty of Twat in 1420 when the English and Burgundians not only
booted the French up their backsides,
but made off with their pantaloons to the treaty was humiliating for France
alongside other stuff.
It's set things up so Henry would inherit the French thrown when Charles died.
But then Henry made the mistake of dying just before Charles also die,
technically making Henry's 10 month old son Henry the sixth king of both
nations.
The French decided that being ruled by a baby was just a bit ridiculous.
So they made Charles of Val walking in Stet and yes,
we were assigned to that old classic French play of screw the trees and blow
raspberries across the channel.
Only the English.
They were no longer across the channel,
but they were occupying the north of France.
Then included not any Paris,
but also runs a city where Charles valid Valois had to be crowns to be
recognized as king.
So that's why things were by 1425 the English and the Burgundian said everything
above the La River while Charles of Valois stewed to the south unable to become
king until he made it to romance.
It would take a miracle to break this deadlock and ends this near century of
conflicts.
Luckily though,
miracles,
what would Joan of arc was all about?
Just as Charles de Valois was sulking around wishing he could be King Young Joan
of arc was having an extremely spooky experience.
Now age 13 Joan's life in Doremi.
It was much the same as it was when we last left town,
but there was one major difference.
As she reached puberty,
Jones started having visions of some Catherine and Margaret of Antioch and some
Michael.
Now at first these visions,
they simply told her to lead a pious life and remain a virgin,
but as time passed they started telling her,
you know,
actually,
how about you become a warrior and you put Charles of firewall on the throne?
And that sounds pretty good right now.
As I said earlier,
female visionaries,
they weren't uncommon in France,
but that doesn't mean that people took them seriously.
The other kids they set and he laughed at Jones visions,
the visions,
they persisted until one day in May of 1428 when Joan was 16 the saints suddenly
told her to go to see Charles and she not now.
This was a bit of a problem.
The war had left steadfastly pro Charles Dahmer me completely surrounded by
hostile Burgundy and territory which you on around 500 kilometers away.
Any Journey Joan undertook on her own would likely have ended up with a debt,
so join didn't even try.
Instead she went to the nearby pro Charles stronghold of Van coolio.
Then she found the garrison commander rob ads and Bowery and she demanded that
he sends out to the rightful king robot.
ADDS about a recall responded by throwing her out on an ear.
When I'm joking here,
he actually told Jones and make sure that her father gave very good beating.
Spends.
Jane went back to dom Remey presumably muttering obscenities the rest of 1428 it
passed rather slowly [inaudible] and father trying to marry her off any for Joan
to successfully argue in court that she'd taken a vow of chastity and must
remain single throughout the proceeds gen kept on talking about her visions to
the points that the news began to seep out to other villages that were even
stirrings,
that she might be the virgin prophesies do need fronds to victory over England's
eventually three Ms.
They reached the bag in d and forces.
They responded by sacking Jones village.
Now Relinda hit the house of Burgundy.
It was allied with England's.
The last thing they wanted was some prophetess saying,
Charles Valois should be the king if the sacking was meant to be a warning.
Though it had the opposite effect.
In January of 1429 June returned to van coolio that she rode their word of a
vision spread.
By the time she reached grabads Boucher core,
she was a minor celebrity Patrick or noticed when Joan repeated a demand to see
Charles Magical unexpectedly agreed.
He gave Jones six armed man as an escort and it's pointed in the direction of
Shinola and just like that Joe Navarro was off to see the king.
Then we get,
you're probably wondering right
now,
why did Beaudry called changes minds something.
It was just to get this pushy peasant off his back.
How this thing though that had taken note of the Burgundians sacking June's
village and realized there must be something to hurt,
but there is a more likely explanation.
By only 1429 the French,
they were desperate.
Then you use of the wall coming in could not be worse.
The English and the Bug Indians were running riots in the north while French
forces were bankrupt and Lo and morale was back in October of 1428 the English
had laid siege to the vital town of Ali.
On word was only on,
was about to fall.
When it did the game,
it would be over for the French.
All of this may be why on February the 13 1429 Joan and so god of six men were
allowed to ride out of Van [inaudible] runs into the unknown.
We really cannot stress just how dangerous this was.
Joan was a girl riding into lawless territory.
It doesn't take much to imagine what set and men might've done to her.
Thankfully drone realize this before setting off.
She cut her hair short and again dressing in men's clothes.
There's evidence that it was more than just a disguise.
During her ride to Shannon on,
Joan adopted the habits of the six men that she was with.
She slept alongside them,
she dressed with them.
She acted like one of the boys.
It's something she would do well serving in Charles's army and it's likely the
key to the respect that a amen had for her live in days off to setting off Joan
and her entourage.
They finally arrived at Shannon.
The stories of what happened next.
Then the stuff of legends.
Charles refuse to admit this strange girl for two days before finally testing
her by hiding among his entourage and calling for her the moment she entered the
room,
Joan,
who couldn't possibly have seen him before,
strode at straight up to trials and declared that should've been charged by God
to lift the siege on all your and make him king.
It was an impressive display and one probably matched in the private meeting
that the two of them had.
Although we can't say for sure because no records of the survive,
what we can see is that Charles emerge from the meeting ready to give a chance.
This was not an easy go to all of the on,
but also to put a case to the church authorities.
The idea was to convince them that God was really working through hot.
Over the next three weeks,
drain fielded questions from a barrage of theologians on said with remarkable
frankness when master provability,
she told them to send it to all the owners so that she could prove herself by
lifting the siege.
Eventually the theologians must've figured it was a worthy shots because they
told Charles to roll with it in a brutal or 1429 Charles agreed.
It's a move that could have ended his crumbling regime.
I mean,
imagine the propaganda.
Fake King's ends diluted girl to die in battle,
but dying is early on.
It didn't even cross Jones mind.
She knew that God was on our side since she was about to prove it
all the time.
Joan was trying to convince channels to send it to all your other legends was
growing.
We know this because the French army was so broke that Charles was relying on
volunteers,
but when he put out a call but basically said,
hey,
he wants to go with this crazy girl that died of ending a random city,
thousands of men,
they actually responded.
It was the first sign of the almost mystical loyalty that June was able to
commands.
On April the 29 1429 Joan and a new army arrived at the siege.
Vone or Joan was riding atop of Whitehall.
Christian banner held high with some quick serve visionary work.
They gained access to the city expecting to be heralded saviors.
Instead,
they found a city on the brink of collapse.
All the old was at that time under the control of a man,
literally calls the bustard of all the arm while the title,
what referred to his parentage.
It could have been used in our modern sense,
the bastard he Luther,
Joan.
He was gearing up to surrender and didn't need some jumped up peasant telling
him that God was going to save them.
He Logs Joan out of meetings and refuse to give that any role.
It was a move designed to get rid of her,
but it was also a move that failed to recognize one important point.
All of the new troops from Shinola loyal to Joan as the rank and file of only
on,
they were already turning to her site on May the fourth Joan was resting when
she suddenly had another vision telling you how to attack the English.
She grabbed us soiled and banner ads race down to the city,
to the east,
just as the French were beginning and assault on a fort at the sight of God.
Seemingly kinds of their side and rallied the French.
As Joan plunged into the thick of the battle,
they the ends of fight heart,
the fort fell and the next day another and another.
By the time may the seventh dorms,
the French had done the impossible that broken the siege.
All that remained was to make a last assault on the English and all [inaudible]
would be saved and the audio is Jen netter army into battle again by now.
The English were aware of the spooky girl who made the French fight light lions
when the is so ha raise a banner,
they took aim Leanna hip drone in the shoulder pissing six inches deep.
It knocked her flat and laughter in agony.
She was dragged from the field for emergency surgery,
had gone to just abandon the French,
not even close that afternoon.
Despite suffering a wounds that would leave most of us curled up on the floor
waiting for our mums.
June returned to the battlefield the size of her banner rising once more in the
afternoon.
Sunlight sent up a great chair from the French.
They routed the English by May,
the eighth thing,
women's forces,
they were in full retreat.
Joan of arc had done exactly what should promise to do and the siege vone all it
was either
if you need proof of the kinds of power Joan of arc has over the people look no
further than what happens after the siege of [inaudible] with the English and
flights.
The French forces went to chase them only to be told by Joan in no uncertain
terms that it was a Sunday and good Catholics.
They didn't fight on a Sunday.
Amazingly,
these rough men,
they listened to the English.
They were allowed to escape.
As they retreated.
It said Joan Wentz and wept over their dead.
A sign of respect that was not be reciprocated at our trial.
Not that there was much time for Jane to weep,
though she already had another task.
She needed to get Charles to Ross.
The problem was that roams wasn't like all the arms sitting on the front lines.
It was deep into the English territory.
She might as well be trying to take him do London,
but Jane,
she gets on pressing and Chelsea was eventually like,
fine,
I'll go,
but you're going to have to clear a path for me first and well,
that's exactly what Joan did over the next few weeks around me.
Stormed up and down the La River.
Liberating towns,
so effective was sheath at the English begins to believe that she was possessed
by the devil.
Well that Joan was particularly satanic.
She never personally fought.
Instead using her banner and bravery to inspire men.
She also absolutely forbid her forces from looting or to rape any women.
The only unusual pause from a medieval perspective was the way she,
that she insisted on dressing with and sleeping alongside men.
It's because of this that modern historians have theorized that she may have
been gay or trans.
Finally,
on June the eighth June's forces met the remnants of the English at the mantle
of Putty to say Jones Army mops the floor with them would be a disservice to
mops.
They absolutely pulverized them after this.
Charles,
he couldn't ignore Joan any longer.
When she came back and told him to get his kingly asked arose.
He absolutely agreed.
As Jane and Charles wrote across the northern France town off town fell without
even putting up a resistance,
they liberated offset Szenol Trois Trois always the place where the French had
had to sign the humiliating treaty with Henry the fifth.
On July the 16th the raw meat finally reached Ross.
The gates open as they approached the city of kings at Folan just two months
ago.
The idea of getting the French all to roles was like asking John,
John,
Bing's do singlehandedly funked his way inside Darth Vader,
his private chambers.
Nope.
Now Joan and channels were triumphant the very next day,
July [inaudible] 17 1429 Charles,
if Ottawa was Carnegie,
had Charles the seventh of France,
which I stood beside him during the ceremony hands afterwards,
she knelt and Colton that king at that points a visions that just stops a
mission.
It was over in his,
God apparently didn't have any more plans,
but it seems Joan had gotten a taste for battle as Charles the seventh embarks
on a victory lap around his newly conquered territories.
The made of only on made a fateful decision.
She decided to go to Paris
on August the 28th 1429 Charles the seventh opens peace negotiations with the
Burgundians.
He wept suddenly not really so hot on their alliance with the using English.
The news gave June the bad feeling that any p street you might block her taking
action against Paris.
This was a big deal as the French capital,
it lay in the hands of the English.
So Joan,
she went rogue on September the eighth she better army out independently to
attack Paris.
This was a major mistake to continue our star wars metaphor.
I'll taking Paris and 40 29 was like trying to break into the death star using
an anchovy,
the walls of the city.
They were nearly 30 feet high.
It's still Joan.
She tried waving,
have banner and demanding the power of surrender.
She got a crossbow through the leg for her trouble and was dragged from the
battlefield screaming as men to continue the assault.
Instead,
they retreated.
When word got back to Charles about what Joan was up to during his delicate
negotiations,
he casts a leafs.
Yup.
Joe might have made him king that Charles had new problem with stopping her
supplies of weapons and men and then basically ignoring her.
While he did allow her to keep fighting,
it was probably just to keep her busy that Joan riding around the liberating the
old small town was a Joan not whipping up disk and tens in the army.
Still.
It wasn't until the spring of 1430 then it became clear just how far Charles was
distancing himself from the girl who had saved his regime during an attempt to
relive a siege on comp PN on May the 23rd June was knocked from a horse behind
enemy lines.
Seeing no point in fighting on.
She allowed herself to be captured by the Burgundian forces.
Everyone expected.
Charles took quickly trade vat.
Everyone they expected wrong channels just didn't lift a finger.
This left the Burgundians in an awkward position.
On the one hand is they wanted to keep Charles happy and signed a treaty with
him.
But on the other hands,
they didn't want to just return.
It is best leaders are the fields to take more Burgundian towns.
So in July of 1430 they'd reached a compromise.
They sold June to the English.
When Joan had the news,
she attempted to commit suicide by leaping from the tower of Castle,
but she survived.
And on January the third 1431 she was handed over to English loyalists in
northern France.
Sorry,
what did the English and their students do when they go to their grubby little
paws on the girl who made Charles the seventh king?
Well,
they took her to rule and they put her on trial
on March the 25th 1431 the Church authorities that wrong charge Joan on 70
religious points ranging from heresy you to addressing in men's clothes.
Whereas as that last one seems it was legit.
Deuteronomy chapter 22 verse five does actually contain their direct prohibition
from God on women wearing men's clothes.
So well now you know Jones prosecutors,
they set theological traps trying to trip her up and doctrine.
One of the key parts of the Joan of Arc myth is that she was able to avoid these
traps and leave the prosecutor's with almost nothing.
Those original 70 challenges.
The authorities were forced to through 58 of them out,
but let's not kid ourselves that this was just a spirited debate about theology.
From the moment she got to Rewind,
Joan was kept in awful conditions.
She was chained to a filthy beds and a filthy prison and given just enough food
to keep her from dying day and night.
Male gods.
They watched her taunting her and threatened her with assault on April the 18th
Jones conditions.
They caused her to fall badly sick,
convinced she was dying.
She begged to be allowed to see a priest.
I request it was refused.
Finally,
on May the 24th the authorities that had enough unable to settle the last 12
points,
they dragged Joan outside for a mock execution and then basically said,
sign this confession,
all that execution.
Next time it's going to be real dry and signed.
The documents contained a very specific clause forbidding her from ever dressing
as a man again under pain of death,
something that this clause was inserted very because a couple of days later the
authorities came to visit Joan in prison and found her dressed as a boy.
The official version is that Joan had claims the saints had audit how to wear
the clothes,
but other sources suggest the cause was far darker.
Supposedly the Med guarding Jones stripped her naked and gave her the choice of
either putting on makeup or clothes or remaining naked before them.
Knowing what would happen if she remains naked.
Genuine,
she chose the clothes regardless of the outcome was the same.
On May the 30th 1431 Joan was led out of plaster view Martians tied to a stake.
It said that one of our gods slipped her a would increase of x on the way in
order to come for tat.
That warm Spring Day,
Joan of arc was burned alive.
The execution that was forbidden from easing a misery by killing her before the
flames reached a flash and Joan died screaming in agony.
I reupholstered lost weds with a pitiful wailing of a teenager begging for some
Michael to rescue her.
The Angel never appeared when the execution was over,
the authorities had to remains burned again and then scattered her ashes in the
river.
The Story of Joan of arc,
it was over,
or was it 19 years off to join was executed.
Charles the seventh road in Rwanda by now the Hundred Years War was winding down
in the French,
were on the verge of winning.
Stood in the city where his ones,
I'm savior Ben to death.
Charles older than an inquiry into Jones trial.
This inquiry ended up at the Vatican wearing 1456 pipe Callixtus the third and
those all charges against her.
When the news reached from Jane was elevated to a motto,
the 116 years of conflict and finally ended in 1493 and wore shattered.
France was in need of a national hero and in Joan they found one.
She's kind of remained there ever since.
On May the 16th 1920 pope benedict the 15th kind of Nice step.
Four days later the French parliament declared a national day and and run a fast
forward to today and she is arguably more famous than Charles the seventh Henry
the fifth or any of the forgotten kings who fought and raged around SAP,
but there's more to Joan's legacy than just being remembered.
You can still see the effect that she had on the [inaudible] wells.
Historians think it's unlikely the channels,
the seventh would have won the hundred years war without June.
That means an English victory,
which is great,
isn't that sounds which haven't been no United French nation just think no.
France,
the French revolution,
which means no to Polian which essentially means new modern world.
Just pick at random,
there would be no metric system,
no Louisiana purchase,
no France to the Americans and the revolutionary wars,
the entire planet.
It was a completely different,
most Joan of arc,
divinely inspired and just it's a new did peasant girl whose belief was enough
to make her a warrior.
It really doesn't matter.
And how short,
19 years on earth,
Joe Navarro changed the weld in ways that even kings and emperors ready to she
man then born and nobody,
but she died Joan of arc,
the heroine of fronts.
So I already have you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
I say we hit that notification bell,
so you actually find out when we put out new videos,
and that's just the way that youtube works these days.
And as always,
CNX time.